pressure continues to mount this weekend
for former national security adviser
Mike Flynn to testify on what he knows
about possible connections between the
Trump campaign and Russia Flynn's lawyer
says Flynn has a story to tell but he
wants his client to have immunity on
Friday mr. Trump encouraged Flynn to ask
for immunity saying the inquiries are
nothing short of a quote witch hunt
Errol Burnett is at the White House with
the latest Errol good morning good
morning while president Trump tries to
make headway on major policy goals he's
facing increasing head winds from the
inquiries into Russian interference
general Mike Flynn a man fired from the
White House for misleading the vice
president now says he wants protection
from prosecution so he can tell
congressional investigative committees
what he knows and that has all of
Washington wondering what exactly that
could be the theft of American
prosperity will end president Trump
signed two executive orders Friday
saying it strengthens the United States
against trade abuse but the President
refused to comment on revelations that
his former national security adviser
michael Flynn is seeking immunity were
you trying to tell the Justice
Department to grant immunity to michael
Flynn were you trying to do that mr.
president earlier the President did fire
off this tweet writing that Flynn should
ask for immunity because the
investigations are a witch hunt press
secretary Sean Spicer said the president
is supportive of Flynn testifying and
dodged questions when asked if the
president is trying to influence the
investigations he could have just said I
testify he said he should get immunity
right and the president's very clear
that he wants Mike Flynn to go and be
completely open and transparent with the
committee and whatever it takes to do
that he is supportive of Flynn's lawyer
released this statement saying Flynn has
a story to tell and confirm negotiations
are underway between his client and the
House and Senate intelligence committees
but even if Flynn is granted
congressional immunity he could still be
prosecuted by the Justice Department
when you got given immunity that means
you've probably committed a crime during
the campaign both Flynn and president
Trump said immunity for Hillary
Clinton's associates
aunt amount of guilt that guilty of a
crime what do you need immunity for even
Republicans like the chairman of the
House Oversight Committee jason Chaffetz
are puzzled by Flynn's request well it
doesn't look good I mean I I don't know
i mean the witch hunt i don't i don't
buy that either we're just trying to get
to the facts congressman Adam Schiff the
top Democrat on the House Intelligence
Committee called Flynn's immunity
request a grave and momentous step shift
went to the White House Friday to review
the intelligence previously provided to
committee chairman Devin Nunez who's
facing questions about possible
coordination with the white house shift
called for the documents to be shared
with the full intelligence committees
now more challenges lie ahead next week
President Trump meets with the Chinese
President Xi Jinping at the mar-a-lago
Resort in Florida president Trump has
already described these upcoming
meetings as very difficult and has
previously labeled China as a currency
manipulator Anthony Errol Barnett at the
White House thanks Errol